When I was a kid
I used to dream what it'd would be like
to live somewhere far away from Hell's Kitchen
but I realized the city was a part of me
it was in my blood
and I would do anything to make it a better place.
Good and evil... sometimes the
difference between the two is a sharp line.
Sometimes it's a blur.
Sometimes we have to do things outside of the law.
We're gonna make a difference. I know it
doesn't feel like it sometimes, but we are.
You're blind but you see so much.
I hear things. You know what they call stuff like that? Gifts. I'm gonna train you,
use it.
There are other ways to see.
I don't see the city anymore,
there's only dark corners.
I'll keep you safe, Karen.
I have to be the man the city needs.
What're you gonna do?
Whatever it takes.
You and I have a lot in common.
We're nothing alike.
The other man's evil does not make you good.
I repect your conviction,
the lone man who thinks he can make a difference.
I'm just trying to make my city a better place.
Maybe if you had an iron suit or a magic hammer
that would explain why you keep getting their asses handed to you.
Hey youtubers, it's Charlie. As you can see they just posted a new Daredevil trailer
mostly focusing on the Kingpin character.
Since I already done a
breakdown of 'The Man Without Fear' in the
comics, the storyline they're adapting for
the TV show,
I'm just gonna do an explainer for
the Kingpin's character and his history in the comics.
There was also some new photos of David Tennant visiting the Marvel offices, those are
pretty cool, then I'll explain little bit. He's playing
Killgrave in the Jessica Jones series. I know everyone's really happy to see David
Tennant join the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
And yes Daredevil, all these Netflix
shows, for those that are asking,
they're part of the MCU, the Marvel
Cinematic Universe,
but don't expect a lot of crossovers with
movie characters. They're mostly keeping
it self-contained to the
other Netflix series, so the characters
that crossover will be on those other
Netflix shows like Luke Cage, Jessica
Jones,
Iron Fist and then the Defenders. Captain
America: Civil War is a pretty likely
candidate for crossovers though.
So, Wilson Fisk, aka the Kingpin of crime. Mostly you probably know him from
some of the cartoons or maybe from the
comics. I think after Frank Miller
started writing the comic book in the
1980s,
he really became more of a Daredevil
character and especially now after this
Daredevil series, that's probably how most people are gonna think about h.im
He was created by Stan Lee and John Romita Sr. in 1967.
His first issue was 'Amazing Spider-Man'
number 50. Stan Lee said he wanted a character
that treated crime like it was only a
business. He treats crime
like Tony Stark treats tech
manufacturing, which is funny because
the was actually a time in the comics
when Kingpin and Tony Stark owned a company together. It was
during a comic series called 'Damage
Control'. He spent most of his early run
in the Spider-Man comics, but then he
transitioned to Daredevil
and he also became a big Punisher villain. Originally he started out
is you know more about a comical mob
type character.
When Frank Miller took over the early
1980s, he got super dark, I mean Frank Miller
he makes everybody dark. I know I said
they adapted Frank Miller's 'Man Without Fear' comic
for the TV series, but he started writing
Daredevil way before that in the 1980s.
'Man Without Fear' didn't come till the
early 90s. The really cool thing is
if you wanna dive deep into Daredevil
comics, especially Frank Miller's run,
like his, you know or so years on Daredevil,
you can read it all for free on Marvel Unlimited.
Wilson Fisk started out as this
overweight child who
kinda got sideline just because he was
a bit of an outcast, like a lot of
Marvel villains,
so he got used to acting through other
people. That's what kinda started
him on the path to becoming a crime boss.
He committed his first murder by age 12,
educated himself in politics
and economics to PhD level, so he's super
smart self-taught,
and learn to become a sumo warrior.
That's why he still looks crazy fat but
he's super strong, it's all muscle,
it just looks like he's fat. He didn't
get the name Kingpin till he was a teenager
and he became a mob boss overtime, like he slowly took over
other mob bosses' territories till he
became the biggest crime boss
in New York City. So as you can see from
Robert Downey Jr. licking his face,
Vincent D'Onofrio gonna be playing
Kingpin on the Daredevil Netflix series.
I'm really excited about this. Vincent D'Onofrio,
he's an amazing method actor, so I'm interested to hear what he does to get
into Wilson Fisk mindset, full-metal
Kingpin.
One really awesome thing that the TV
series is doing that's a little bit
different from the comics
is it's telling the origin story of the
Kingpin. So even though it's called Daredevil,
it as much about the Kingpin as it is
about the Daredevil character.
That's one thing that the TV does better
than movies and comics, so like
a lot of times, in the comics, you'll see
a retelling an origin story,
and inside of that you'll have like a mini
story that'll tell the origin
of whatever the villain of the series is.
TV, just by its nature, has a lot more
time to tell
each characters stories. So because they
cast such a big actor
and they have 13 hours to tell this story,
they're telling the origin story
of Kingpin as they tell the origin story
of Daredevil.
It just makes for a much more rewarding
conclusion when we get to the finale.
You know he's not just a regular old,
villain that the hero has to defeat.
He's a really deep character that's been
driven to crime by circumstances in his life
As you saw on the trailer, that gallery that he's in is owned by his wife
I don't wanna give any spoilers away if
you haven't read the 'Man Without Fear' storyline
but she is critical to his character
development in the storyline, that'll
play out across the TV series.
So don't worry if you have read the comic, the TV series will make it pretty easy to follow
I think a really good contrast with the
way Daredevil is doing its villain story
is that it's like a like a 50-50
situation with hero story-villain story,
as opposed to like Agents of SHIELD which is like 75% about
heroes and 25% about the villains.
Like you just don't spend as much time with
certain characters, so it's not quite as
rewarding when you get to the finale, so
I think that if you really like villain
stories Daredevil is going to be a lot more fun.
And they did say because it's Netflix,
it's not network television,
they're not watering it down for general
audiences it's going to be super dark and gritty.
So, if you like really dark crime drama
up with a lot of violence
you're going to have a lot of fun with
this. If you do want to read some really
cool Daredevil stories
in the comics, and you have Marvel
Unlimited, you can totally read them for free.
So, hint: get Marvel Unlimited. You should
totally check out
'Man Without Fear' just because that's the
story they used for the TV series.
Some other really good ones are: 'Kingpin
Must Die!', that story line started with
issue number #170;
early Frank Miller Daredevil, early
80s Daredevil,
It's kinda like Kingpin in Japan, which
kinda reminds me of Wolverine in Japan;
then there's 'Gangwar!', which is the story
line that happen right before that
'Kingpin Must Die!',
also early Frank Miller. Kingpin's wife,
Vanessa, is a big part of it.
Obviously on the TV series because she's
the part in the story. It's really good
because you get some extra context
into what his relationship with his
wife is like and how it informs his character.
Fast forward to 2010 there was a run
called 'Shadowland', that was a
a self-contained mini series where
Kingpin crossed over with
Spider-Man, Iron Fist, Luke Cage
and Moon Knight. It's a great story and
it's also fun because I a lot of those
characters are gonna be inside Defenders,
not Moon Knight though, not Moon Knight or Spider-Man. A lot of you guys have been
asking and I don't know if I made this clear or not but yes, I am doing videos
for Daredevil. Because they're dumping
all of the episodes, all 13
on April 10th, when I'm probably gonna do
is just post like a new video for Daredevil
every couple days, because it's like the
same weekend that Game of Thrones is
premiering. So I can't do like 13 videos
in two days.
But be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you're just finding me for the first
time, if you're brand new here.
Here's a really big question for you
guys: which of the movie characters do you
wanna see on a TV series?
You know, they haven't confirmed any
the cameos outside of the other Netflix characters,
I think they're trying to keep itself
contain, but they shot most the Daredevil
before they cast Luke Cage
or Jessica Jones, so I'm not expecting a
ton of cameos in season 1 of Daredevil.
Season 2 is a whole different story
though.
Which Avenger do you wanna see in Hell's
Kitchen on Daredevil season 2?
Because they're street-level heroes, I'd mostly expect to
see like Agents of SHIELD characters
or like the non-powered Avengers like
Hawkeye or Black Widow
Hawkeye's the likely candidate. There's also rumors that he's gonna be on Agents of SHIELD this year
So really important date: April 10th, is
when all the episodes are going live,
probably at midnight, so you should be
able to marathon all 13 if you want to.
Don't worry, I won't be posting all 13 of my
videos right away, so you don't have to worry
about spoilers or anything if you not gonna
watch them like all right at once way.
While you yous wait for that stuff to drop you can click here
for all my Daredevil l videos from my last trailer video, my explainer for the 'Man Without Fear' storyline,
and you can click here for my explainer
video on Scarlet Witch in the comics and the movies,
and all my other Avenger's' videos.
Thank you so much for watching, I'll see you guys tonight.
Now let's all do the thing.